bonsoir nous nous retrouvons à nouveau
en direct du Festival de Cannes où cette
deè journée a été marquée par la sortie
du film événement d'Edouard nirmans le
retour de Casanova et par l'apparition
événement de Casanova de longon son
arrivé au palais évidemment n'est pas
passé
inaperçu
anceance une cue évidemment inévitable
j'allais dire une cue programmée mais il
faut dire que comme hier les canois
étaient fort nombreux devant les marche
du palais encore plus nombreux ce soir
le temps est dans son absence ce matin
l'absence d'Alain Delon à la conférence
de presse traditionnelle n'est pas passé
inaperçu non plus il a suscité quelques
critiques Alain Delon ne laisse jamais
indifférent et bien l'acteur s'en
expliquera dans l'entretien qu'il nous a
accordé tout à l'heure pe son peu avant
son arrivée sur les marches du palais un
entretien vérité qui portera sur son
rôle de séducteur vieillissant dans le
film de nirmance sur le sentiment de
solitude qu'il peut éprouver parfois et
sur le regard des autres sur lui un
regard dont il attend beaucoup ce soir
Alain Delon en ce moment même se trouve
dans le Palais du Festival et regarde
son film au milieu du jury au milieu du
monde du cinéma qui peut se montrer
féroce quelquefois Alain Delon éprouve
il nous l'a dit une certaine fébrilité
je dirais une certaine humilité nouvelle
chez lui ce sera le temps fort de cette
édition spéciale après évidemment
l'actualité que vous présentez ellise